tomorrow will mark 40 years since one of
the worst disasters in nevada history
a deadly fire at the former mgm grand
hotel and casino
killed 87 people and it injured hundreds
more
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
sits down with the people who not only
help
fight the flames but also those who
survived
these are gaming chips that were melted
together
mementos and memories these are pictures
of
both the building the fire
charlie lombardo shares snapshots
showing the devastation of the deadly
mgm grand fire 40 years ago
this is a crop table this was the casino
cage just burned
just just burn reminders of the morning
the former slot mechanic survived
it was a fireball video from that day
shows plumes of smoke rising from the
building the aftermath of an electrical
fire in the deli restaurant
it spread through the casino which did
not have sprinklers
lombardo recalls crawling on his hands
and knees to get out
after hearing an overhead announcement
to evacuate the building
when i went maybe six eight feet i
thought this is nuts
and i turned around and went back
because it was clear behind me
[Applause]
he eventually found an exit but not
before warning colleagues in a coin
counting room to get out
i went pounder on the door got their
attention
and i as they were opening the door i
could see smoke
coming out of the air vents in that room
there were a lot of people
up and going up and down the hallways
meanwhile firefighters like stanley
gris-manus kiss ran inside
there were there were never any fires
like it of course
you know that was pretty pretty dramatic
grismaniskis cleared the 17th and 23rd
floors
he came across bodies in the rooms and
hallways
there were so many dead people right at
the elevators
that i had to move creating a path to
help people escape to the roof
and get air lifted out by helicopters
there's the helicopter his wife
becky also seen the bodies later that
evening there were
a bunch of them by the registration desk
and they were literally burned
to death in a motion like running
the former criminal investigator at the
district attorney's office probed the
fire
looking for building code violations to
determine county liability
it was that's terrible and you know you
don't ever forget that
a burning memory with a keepsake a
gaming chip
similar to lombardos just a few items
that remain from that day
on the strip kristen drummond 8 news now
and that fire four decades ago led to
various safety reforms including fire
sprinklers and other safety measures
becoming standard